hi there this is your first lesson that
link French scientists you all
salutations greetings before we get
started look at the picture of the far
lifting in the forest that is how
language learning is everything is
unclear at the beginning and gradually
becomes clearer as you listen to more of
the language as we read more of the
language as we learn more words and
phrases using the link system but these
little video guides are just to help you
get started in the language Bonjour
good day you'll notice that it's both
the adjectives here is in yellow that
means it's masculine in French we have
masculine and feminine nouns Bonjour
good day is masculine same with Bonica
needy but one thing that well notice
right away is that the bone has that
good nasal sound in French but bone
Apanui because the N is followed by a
vowel on the next word it's bone up I
mean we don't say bone a committee we
say bon a committee because the end
carries on to the next word and then we
have Bernie and all of a sudden the boys
become but not Bo and any because knee
is feminine
remember in French some words are
masculine and some words are feminine
and I can tell you from personal
experience it will take you a long long
time to get used to which words are
masculine and which are feminine you
just have to slowly let your brain get
used to it now we have bosu-ball FM Edie
bun me and then o or voix which means
till the next meeting and the next
meeting or what is masculine and all is
just taking the AH add or two and look
the to the next meeting and it combines
to become oh don't worry about it this
is just to let you know what's there I
don't expect that you'll remember this
but you'll gradually get used to it as
it
comes up again and again in the either
dialogues and of course we all know I
think many you may know the term comment
allez-vous how are you and to the
frenches how go you Olay is to go and
who is used amount Telugu and the answer
is Joe Vidya and we'll see here these
verbs are in red that unlike in English
words go and go you go I go in French
with every person with Joe the verb
changes and you will have to gradually
get used to that you can always google
the verb aller and you will see all the
different forms but it's hard to
remember them so you just have to slowly
slowly get used to them using the link
system